hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to by now
most of us have figured out that M night
Shyamalan is a one twist pony or two we
all know that six cents is the one that
everybody loves but everyone seems to
have that second shamble on film that
whether it's actually bad or not can't
help but feel a special fondness for and
now today it's so bad it's good way but
more of a legitimate this was a well
made film way and that film for me is
unbreakable now that's not to say it
doesn't have Shyamalan seal of
pretentiousness all over it the
pointless panning longshots the obvious
color symbolism the camera angles that
I'm sure means something to him but not
really to anyone else but yes this is
the other film I actually took seriously
throughout the majority of it and I
won't even conjured up some interesting
ideas even if I'm not sure the film is
aware of these ideas itself to explain
what I mean I have to talk about the
film as a whole so fair warning there
are spoilers all throughout this
analysis so if you haven't seen the
movie yet and want to be surprised stop
now and go see it with that said for
those who have seen it you know it's
about a man played by Bruce Willis who
is the only survivor of a train crash
and has no marks on it he's approached
by another man played by Samuel Jackson
who tells him that there is a plant set
out for him one that's been told time
and time again over the centuries it's
the basic plan of good versus evil I
hero versus a villain from Greek
mythology to fairy tales to modern day
comic books there is a pattern of this
epic battle that equals an underlying
truth that is going on in reality as
well as opens up to the idea that he is
in fact one of these heroes he realizes
that he has many similar qualities he
has a weakness
he seems practically indestructible he
seems inhumanly strong and he can also
sense when wrongdoers have done wrong
things once he decides to use this power
to battle those wrongdoers we get of
course our twist ending Daniel Jackson
was in fact the villain the whole time
killing tons of innocent people
including the train crash Willis was in
until he discovered the indestructible
hero as the saying goes what a twist
when people saw this movie many didn't
know what to think of it most people
dismissed it as false advertising seeing
how the trailer showed a serious drama
based on a supernatural element but then
out of the blue they got a comic book
movie instead most going in we're now
looking for heroes and green caves and
villains in purple cars but even with
that is unbreakable an actual bad movie
it still has the drawn-out dialogue it
slow-moving pace that most shamble on
films have but I feel there's something
a little deeper that can be taken out of
it the ending particularly seems to make
or break the film for a lot of people
some say it wasn't needed others say
it's what gave the film its purpose
watching it again I felt like there was
a really great idea in it that maybe the
film itself didn't realize was there
what's the theme of the film as well as
really the theme of any Shyamalan film
that there's a great plan and everything
that happens happens for a reason
been there done that but this film
whether it realizes it or not gives a
very cryptic and uncomfortable angle to
it Jackson throughout most of the film
is not the bad guy he's born with a
disease where his bones easily break
which has led to a life of misery and
pain all he wants to do is belong he
wants to fit into something that has
greater meaning so that he no longer
feels worthless when his revelation of
life having a great plan is discovered
he realizes he is meant to be the bad
guy
and forever give purpose to those who
discover they're meant to be heroes yeah
a lot of people may see it as just a
basic good versus evil story but in my
opinion this is a kind of creepy idea so
many people lean towards the comforting
and nurturing prospects of everything
having a point that the universe has a
grand plan for us but this film gives
off the vibe that it's actually not such
a good thing there is no free will
there is no deciding your own destiny
there is no choice you can make on your
own why because you're just a puppet and
the grand plan look
even before he reveals the truth about a
fill and his identity he's at an art
gallery of his collected works everybody
is praising him his mother has never
seen him happier everything seems to be
going his way
a great deciding factor of life declares
he can't be that nope he's the bad guy
plain and simple
by this definition the movie suggesting
that you can't change who you are you
can't redeem whatever faults you've had
if you're destined to become a villain
one way or another that's what you will
become what an absolutely horrifying
notion it's great for the hero and all
the people who are saved by him or her
but what about the people who don't want
to be mean or how about the poor victims
who are just pawns in their battle I've
known so many people who look up to so
many films about there being a
predestined plan that will always work
out in the end and there's nothing wrong
with that if that's your belief you can
of course choose to take comfort in it
as much as you want the film is also
about different points of view and this
one is so rarely seen at least in terms
of movies the idea of predestined life
which is all part of the grand plan can
be the death of conscious choice it just
makes us chess pieces characters in
somebody else's story that we can't
change and rather than finding comfort
in this this film actually finds it
disturbing
again I can't think of that many films
that have actually taken that angle now
with that said is this most likely with
Shyamalan had in mind I have no idea his
other films like signs for example seem
to indicate that life is best if you
just trust the grand plan and totally
give yourself to it so it's totally
possible this is all just a coincidence
but even if it was these ideas can still
be suggested as I said before an artist
take on their own work doesn't have to
be your take on it for me
I'll breakable is an almost uplifting
film that's shattered by a disturbing
message that enforces the importance of
free will it's a point of view that's
not often seen in mainstream movies and
one that hasn't been told in such a
unique way now if you don't see that in
its message and are still turned off by
the other Shyamalan isms I'm not gonna
act like I don't understand it's all
there it is kinda silly you can
definitely see the beginnings of many
cliches that shallow I would use over
and over and over but perhaps something
can be read into it that even the
filmmakers themselves didn't play
maybe there can be something very
different of value from a director who
has turned out so little of it in the
past
I'm not like this is any grand
masterpiece but it's given enough proof
or thought that I'm glad I watched it it
questioned an outlook not many movies
questioned and opened up a point of view
that some of us had never really
considered I doubt we'll be praising it
in the future is one of the grades but
with every other schoville on film being
so obvious and blunt in its messages
it's nice to finally have one that can
be a little open to interpretation life
having a grand plan can be very
comforting but it can also be very scary
it's an interesting take that definitely
got a lot of minds thinking and a lot of
conversations going and any film that
does that can't be all bad
in the same way the films that just
basic good and evil outlooks maybe too
simple maybe we can also see that the
bad outlook of a director could also be
just as simple and that maybe we can
find a little bit more value there than
we originally thought
Tad's besides he did give us this what
no I will never get tired of that I'm
the Nostalgia Critic I remember it so
you don't have to
you